you need to track your expenses for 30
days for 30 days go track your expenses
and like two people did it right so then
i was like okay you know what the seven
day challenge in fact i think we did
this we did this on oprah you know for
seven days track your latte factor oprah
when i did the one of the oprah shows
she we showed the lattice factor and she
pulled off a cloth and showed this
woman's latte factory and we had a
quarter of a million dollars in cash
sitting on this table and we told people
for seven days track your expenses
a lot of people did that like tens of
thousands of people tracked their
expenses for seven days so i would love
it
if people would go and take the
challenge and for seven days track where
their money's going everything you know
people are like well does that include
cash yes does that inflate tam card yes
checks yes visa everywhere your money
goes for seven days track it and at the
end of seven days look at it
and tell yourself well what's in here
that could be changed
now i will say this some people can't
get through seven days really so really
so
a lot of times and i could do it right
now i say you know what just do it for
one freaking day
one day one day just take one day and
take a pad of paper and just write down
where your money goes for one day and
the only key here is don't change who
you are during that day don't go you
know don't change your behavior just
spend money like you always do and if
again if you're in a relationship have
your partner do this
and then look at it and be honest with
yourself
you know i always think benjamin
franklin was famous for saying a penny
spent a penny saved is a penny earned
well today i'd say five bucks saved is
five bucks earned for some people the
latte factor is not five bucks it's a
hundred bucks or it's a hundred thousand
dollars i mean i've done speeches for
people where the average liquid net
worth in the room was 10 million dollars
and i have the person say don't talk
about the latte factor and i'd say don't
worry i will i'm gonna bring up their
jets and their fifth home that they
don't use and people would come up like
he's right i have a fifth home and i
never use it you know that's my latte
factory we don't need the fifth home and
you know wherever that fifth home was so
um but it's a metaphor to look at where
you spend money and and you and i were
talking before we started this that
what people do it's fascinating
they
they inflate what they earn in their
mind and they underestimate what they
spend so if someone's making let's say
55 000 a year if i ask them
what do you make a year they're going to
tell me not 55 they're gonna tell me 60.
people always do this they oh and they
mentally do it too person who's making
80 mentally stretches that they make 100
and but they don't
and then they tell you if somebody tells
you they're spending 70 i promise you
they're not spending 70 they're spending
80 or 90. so we we inflate in our minds
what we earn and we
underestimate what we spend and it's
actually the opposite
you need to spend less than you earn and
then you need to increase what you make
if you if you spend less than you earn
and you increase what you make it's
total victory wanna be happy build a
life not just a business hey it's evan
carl michael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
michael jordan level genius at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn the seven steps to start
building massive wealth
enjoy
step number two pay yourself first with
bob proctor talk about people paying
themselves they pay everything under the
sun but they don't pay themselves
think of when you're on a plane
and
the oxygen mask may drop down
there's a problem with oxygen in the
plane
they will tell you if you have a child
with you put your own on
because you can't look after the kids if
you haven't got your self looked after
well that's exactly the same with money
look after yourself first if you don't
pay yourself
you're soon
teach yourself and just not do very well
step number three multiply wealth with
grant cardone how do we multiply
rather than add yeah so incremental yeah
so look the the comment about you
everybody knows how to add and subtract
what they don't know how to do is
multiply the concept areas
is
you're trying to make incremental
changes like okay i made a million
dollars last year everybody's very
rational when the year comes around okay
we did a million last year what can we
do
uh we could do we could grow about 10 or
15 percent you're never going to grow
like that successfully i know it makes
sense but it don't make money
and by the way y'all should always
remember this when somebody says that
make sense okay it might make sense but
it doesn't mean it's gonna make money
because what happens when you go from a
million dollars okay like when you go
from what happens
and this is what i used to try to do and
it didn't work
is when you go let's say you figured out
how to run a business on a million
dollars of income
or you call it turnover right
right so you're like okay what are we
going to do this year last year we did a
million dollars and some smart person in
the back of the room that doesn't even
know how to get money talk to anyone
uh they're in a board room they've never
actually made contact with another human
being they're like we i think we can
grow the business 15 this year we should
be able to go 15 okay so they're like
which is an ad it's an ad okay okay
we're gonna grow the business 150 grand
and then and they don't plan on anything
bad happening
there's like this is a universe where
there's no gravity no kovid no gravity
no war
no disruption in the marketplace no new
technology nothing so by the way this
might not even keep with inflation in
some cases like
housing in america has inflated at 11
this year already
so i wouldn't even keep up with that so
what happens when you do incremental ads
you never get ahead enough number one
and number two you never plan for the
setbacks number three the most important
thing is
you don't get a new set of problems
you get the same problems over and over
okay you guys did talk about burnout all
the time let me tell you where to burn
you out dealing with the same damn
problems over and over and over again
give me a new problem please something i
have not you give me anything new i'm
ready you give me the same [ __ ] over
and over and over and over again you
freaking wear me out okay so how do i
get new problems i wrote about this in
the 10x rule
when you go 10x the first thing that
will happen is a new set of problems
always
why do i want new problems
because new problems require new answers
new questions new people
new thinking
old problems require no new think
it's the same thing over and over again
so you don't get any creativity here
over here we want to multiply in this
case
hey guys the goal should be this this is
simple
okay my meeting is going to be faster
than your meeting they came up with
something analytical i came up with
something unreasonable
unreasonable in a good way hey guys
we're going to go from 1 million dollars
to 10 million who do we need to buy
where do we need to get the money how
many customers do we need to see how
much inventory would i have is it even
possible oh my god that's not possible
is there 10 million dollars
on planet earth yes good then it's
possible now how do we go there so what
i'm trying to do is get myself oh my god
we would have to hire 50 more people
good new problem rather than complaining
about the five people you have
that's how you multiply also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there step number four avoid significant
losses with warren buffett i've got this
rule you know the first rule is don't
lose in the second rule is never forget
the first rule so it really isn't so
much having a lot of brilliant decisions
it's just not really having some
terrible ones and and and frankly i did
learn from ben graham how to avoid
ever having any disasters and
investments
it wasn't that you were going to come up
with the very smartest thing but if you
never have any
any significant losses
you know some singles and doubles will
produce a lot of runs before you get
through step number five aim to acquire
assets with robert kiyosaki so there's
basically four asset classes that makes
a person rich
and there's lots of more the subheadings
and all this but number one is a
business
the richest young guys today start
companies it's called facebook google
apple stuff like that you know
number two is real estate
so what my rich dad taught me it's a
combination being an entrepreneur in
business and entrepreneur in real estate
it's that combinations i pay no tax
and i make a lot more money
okay so a lot of guys say i have a
business i say well
how much real estate you got without
real estate you pay tax that's the
problem
and then there's paper
which is stocks bonds mutual funds and
savings that's what most people should
be in recent savings or gold main paper
is good like stock spelling mutual funds
are liquid you make a mistake and get in
and out real quick
go liquid the trouble with these two you
make a mistake you're there forever you
can't get in and out
so that's why you can be very smart
before you go in and the last is
commodities
and um you know it's my own oil
and as the price of oil goes down people
say you're losing money i said no
because in the u.s
if you deal on oil
get tax breaks i must invest a million
in oil i get eight hundred thousand back
so i get eighty percent return day one
so oil is very very profitable that's
what but i don't invest in oil stocks
very different
okay so if oil goes to twenty dollars a
barrel i'm still cash i'm still making
money
so it's at about 40 right now hope it
doesn't go too much farther but i still
make money step number six secure the
future with tony robbins what should i
be
you know going all in on should as you
know millennials that are starting
businesses like many people in our
community uh they've you know going all
in on their business and you know
they're sacrificing profit for growth
you know so they don't have that much
spare change what what's your advice
there what are your thoughts what i'm
really glad you asked me that question
because every entrepreneur i meet i have
this conversation with one-on-one people
that are my friends
um and i do it in my business seminars
too when i show people i do business
boot camps and i i spend five days i'm
about to grow their business 100 plus
and then i take a half a day and show
them what to do to have a second
business here's what i'd say to you if
you're a founder out there if you're
somebody's starting an organization
the amount of money that you get
whatever cash you have if it's a growing
business will always be eaten up by the
organization so a friend of mine ken
blanchard who wrote the one minute
manager books you may have read years
ago
i met him 30 years ago and i helped him
take five strokes off his golf game so
he thought i was god
and i don't play golf i just know what
to do here and here with somebody and so
afterwards he goes i want to do
something for you i said look i you know
what do you know anything about two
months later it calls me up says i want
to lunch with you i want to give you a
gift
he said i want to share with you the
best financial advice that changed my
life so what is it
he said this very wealthy friend of mine
saw i was writing a book
and he saw us growing my business and he
said i want to tell you something a
business he said what i told you earlier
we'll take whatever cash is there
because a growing business there's
always needs yeah he said you have to
draw a line in the sand and he said your
book should be the first line in the
sand you should put none of that money
in your company
the clients that like the book will
become clients of the company and you
shouldn't take that money you should put
an investment account that you don't
touch
and it continues to compound to create
financial freedom he said tony i took
his advice
and then i went through three different
stages where we almost went bankrupt in
the business because i had so much cash
and money i wasn't stressed so i was
they'll keep my head straight and run my
business better because if you think
about and i bet i did that too i did my
first books now i give away all the
profits in my books my first books and
my first infomercials yes and i work you
know 275 days a year on the road
i never earned as much as i did by
compounding because compounding changes
the game so what you have to do if
you're a business owner
you have to get yourself where you say
i'm going to put a tax on my business
not the government tax my tax my future
self is going to be free forever because
look
in business
96 of businesses don't make it in 10
years i'm sure all of yours will but
even the four percent that make it
aren't necessarily profitable
so and the reason is because government
can change the rules right taxes can
shift radically affected clients shift
their preferences technology new
competition so i tell everybody i
believe you'll make your business
succeed but everybody should have a
business on the side with no employees
no moving parts
20 minutes 15 minutes 30 minutes a year
to rebalance it so that if anything
happens here you're still strong and you
can make this stronger or if this goes
well and this goes well as well you have
twice as much money and you're there but
you got to understand what this
compounding does right this compounding
you don't need a lot of money to get
really really wealthy
you know the example of one example i
put in the book here was the example of
a man who talks to a son he's 18 years
old and the man understands finance and
understands the power of compounding so
he says to his son you got your first
job you're 18.
i'm going to require
that you take 300 every month 150 bucks
a paycheck and we're gonna automate it
to the separate account and it sounds
like i can't do that he goes let me tell
you why you want to do it it'll be up to
you
if you promise to do that you really do
it you automate it so you don't see it
and you do that for eight years
you'll never have to invest again and
you'll be financially set for life this
thing goes come on dad eight years three
dollars a month what is that if he does
the math he goes that's twenty eight
thousand
you know over here twenty eight thousand
eight hundred dollars twenty eight
thousand eight hundred how's that going
to do anything especially if i don't
have any more money after 27 years old
he goes let me show you something the
market's gone up 10
over 30 years let's apply a lower number
let's do 8 be conservative let me show
you what the numbers are when they
compound you know how much he has when
he retires 1.8 million dollars and all
he put in was 28 800. and step number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus clips is increase your
ability to earn with kevin o'leary what
areas of the world do you like right now
where you're investing you know i look
at it very simplistically i say where's
the gdp growth because that's the rising
tide for any operation a telco a toll
road a consumer goods company you'd
rather own that in a country that has
gdp growth north of three percent so
right now you know i used to be 70
invested in canada i'm down to less than
25 here because we're not growing we're
not growing in the us i like brazil
india china asia cambodia thailand they
got it cooking over there they're
growing so i'd rather own the brazilian
telco than any canadian telco i mean you
look at the the worst returns in telco
or in canada you can buy a brazilian
telco that's been a phenomenal
investment for the last five years and
the great thing about these companies
overseas is they're so big now so huge
they're issuing the securities in u.s
dollars and i can hedge that back to the
canadian dollar for next to nothing
people often ask me what is your
business mod 11 how do you make money
this is it this is my business model i
kick up as much noise in my industry i
get as much attention as possible in my
industry and then i find ways to
monetize it that's it when you have a
lot of attention in your industry people
will find you and throw opportunities at
you my biggest challenge is trying to
figure out now which opportunity to go
after i get speaking gigs because of the
attention i built my youtube channel i
get opportunities to connect with people
like tony robbins and have them be
interviewed on my channel i get brand
deals with people wanting to partner
with me i get book deals
everything has come because of my
youtube channel because i built up a
quarter of a billion views because i
have one point whatever million
subscribers i just kick up a lot of
attention in my industry and then deals
come to me and that works really well
for someone like me because i'm
introverted because i'm much better at
marketing than i am at sales and so
instead of me spending time which would
be more wasted time going out trying to
connect with people trying to reach
people because i'm introverted i just
get to work on creating amazing content
and i have people then find me and fly
me out to places and pay me to do things
because i built up the marketing
attention machine and so if you want to
do that as well i'm going to give you a
seven-step process that i use every
single time for whatever platform i'm
going after that you can win and model
as well okay step number one is you have
to decide to get attention you have to
decide you have to say i am going to go
out and get attention because all the
strategies that i'll give you and others
will throw at you as well will not work
unless you've decided there's a whole
bunch of people who have made it in the
offline world that now come to me and
say hey evan can you help me blow up
online and say yes i'm happy to help i
love your message but you have to be
committed to doing this this isn't just
some strategy that's going to help you
you have to be committed to be able to
make content and that you are picking a
platform that you're going to blow up on
and you're going to be committed to
doing it it's not just some strategy you
got to love it you got to be all in you
have to decide i am going to blow up on
this platform and so number one
get out of your own way get out of your
ego it's not about you blowing up
personally because you want to look like
a rock star understand that the more
that you blow up the more that people
understand your story this is your
gateway to close sales because the thing
that'll make you different than the big
corporations why am i going to hire you
why would i work with you instead of
some big corporation big corporation
they have a history they have a
reputation
they have a brand name they've been
around forever why am i going to work
with you
because i know your story because i like
you because i feel like you care not
some giant corporation but if you don't
tell me that if i don't feel that if you
haven't blown up if you're not deciding
to get attention then i'm never going to
know the difference between you and john
corporation and then i'm going to make
my decision only off of price and if
your strategy is to be the low price
provider that's a losing game long term
and so step number one is you have to
decide that you are committed to this
year i'm going to get attention because
it's the best thing not just for me it's
the best thing for my business it's the
best thing for my family it's the best
thing for my community and it's the best
thing to further serve my mission it's
not about you and your ego it's about
the mission and the business and your
family you need to get attention step
number two is pick your best platform
there's lots of different platforms out
there the one that you should go with is
the one where number one your audience
is so if you're picking a big platform
like youtube or instagram it serves a
big audience if you have a specific
audience so if you want to do business
and you can go to linkedin
right if you want to do the tech
community twitter is going to be a
better bet for you if you want to target
pre-teens and you want to be on snap
depending on what your market is where
your audience is you want to pick your
platform then you want to pick what are
you the best at doing so i love making
videos so youtube is a great platform
for me maybe you love writing maybe
writing is your preferred method maybe
you don't want to be in front of a
camera great maybe you love audio and so
you'd rather do a podcast than make a
youtube video great when you can figure
out where your audience is
that also matches with your skill set
then pick that one social media platform
and go all in on that one people often
say well you got to be everywhere you
gotta have all your accounts i disagree
at the start i think you should have an
account on each platform one just to
have the account just that nobody else
can take your name
and squat on it and and ruin your
reputation potentially and two just to
listen so if twitter is not your main
platform but somebody tweets at you you
want to be able to respond and you want
to encourage them they're your champions
they're out spreading your message for
you but if you try to be everywhere all
at the same time at the beginning when
it's just you doing it
every platform is gonna suck you're
gonna do everything in a really mediocre
way i'd much rather have you focus on
one platform go and crush it go and
dominate it and as you scale up and
build a team then you can go and branch
out to the other ones so pick that
single best platform for you step number
three commit the posting every day
every day you have to post every single
day whatever platform you're on you have
to commit to posting every single day
youtube is probably the platform where
you can get away with not posting every
day
but i post three times a day
and yes i built my team that's helped me
be able to do that and yes you may not
be able to do it right from the
beginning but that is your ambition i
want you posting every single day
whatever you're picking youtube
instagram linkedin
snap facebook pinterest wherever you're
going if you're posting every single day
you have a much bigger chance of getting
the attention of getting your message to
spread than if you're posting every week
or every two weeks or once a month
and then you might say well i want the
quality the quality has to be high right
it has to be good i don't want to
release crap yes
100
but if you can get to the point where
you are releasing 80 quality every day
instead of 100 quality once a week do
the 80
now if it's gonna come down to 50
quality
now we've got an issue but if you can
release at 80 and do it more frequently
you will grow you will blow up you will
get more attention and your mission will
be served you will reach more people you
will sell more you will get more
attention and start to win harder you
need to at least get on the map get on
the path have a vision to do the posting
daily that is in your mindset you are
building the business that you can post
daily whether you can do it right now or
at least it's on your game plan
you can't be stuck in posting any less
step number four is learn how to create
great content i get so many people who
write to me and say hey i'm making great
content but i'm not winning what's up
how do i get better how do i promote
myself more chances are your content's
not that good
listen i'm being honest your content is
not that good
first step for that is watch your own
content back would you consume you would
you would you watch your video of your
message and say wow that was really good
like watch your own content back
would you subscribe to your channel and
if the answer is no then that's a big
problem you have to make content that
you are proud of and you have to learn
how to do it and i'm a big believer that
the quantity leads to quality that the
more you do if you commit to posting
daily you will figure out how to get
better really quickly if you're only
posting once a week it's going to be
hard to get really good quickly because
it's just taking you too long if you're
trying to learn french and you go to
class once a week you'll just learn so
much slower than if you're going every
day
right so you need to learn how to make
great content and don't default to
thinking that you're making great
content you deserve to be where you're
at somebody has seen your content and
they haven't shared it
you guys are watching this video some of
you will share it some of you won't the
ones of you who share will think this is
great and the ones of you don't
won't
i need to get better right the content's
not good enough i need to improve my
skills i need to be a better
communicator i need to get to the point
faster i need to have more energy
there's lots of things i need to work on
people who say i deserve to have 10
million subscribers on my youtube
channel i don't
i'm not good enough the content's not
good enough now i deserve my 1.7 i
deserve to be where i'm at i'm not
garbage
right but i don't deserve to have my 10.
and so you don't deserve anything you
deserve to be where you're at people are
watching your content every single day
hopefully but they're not sharing it
that's on you it's never been easier for
them to share it they're not doing it
because it's not good enough so default
not to some marketing tactic or strategy
default to how can i get better at the
skill of making amazing content step
number five is listen and respond to
every single comment i believe that
every comment should get a response it
doesn't have to be you doing it every
time at the beginning it probably should
be so you can learn and taste and see
how people reacting to it as you grow
though you want to have somebody on your
team managing your comments just like in
every other customer facing part of your
business
right if somebody is calling your store
if you sell flowers and somebody's
calling your store you want somebody to
pick up and talk to that customer right
if somebody's emailing your store and
saying hey i'd like to buy something you
want to give them a response right
somehow in the world of social we've
decided that it's okay to ignore our
customers
it's okay not to respond how most people
do it is at the beginning they say okay
i'm gonna respond to every comment great
no problem it's easy because you're
getting one comment a day that's super
easy but as you build up people will
then say well i'm only going to respond
to the important people i'm only going
to respond to the people who have a
certain number of followers or i'm only
going to spend an hour a day responding
to comments
just hire somebody like you would for
every other part of your business that's
customer facing everybody needs a
response but it doesn't have to be you
doing it when you respond to somebody on
youtube as an example they're seven
times more likely to subscribe you're
asking for people's attention right
you're asking for them to care about you
but you're not spending any time caring
back about them the amount of people who
want to grow their channels on any
platform but they're spending zero time
in their comments
you're losing
and so i'm probably the only one at this
size who's really hardcore about
responding to comments and have hired
somebody to do it i just think it's
important i think if you're not
responding every comment you're leaving
free subscribers free attention on the
table
just go for it it's so much easier step
number six understand the hacks of each
platform
eighty percent of success
comes back to step number four which is
learn to make great content that's
eighty percent of your success eighty
percent of your success is coming down
to do you know how to make an emotional
piece of content that makes people feel
something and then move into action the
other 20 is understanding the hacks so
for instagram hashtags means a lot for
posting stories versus pictures versus
videos there's different strategies for
each one going to youtube hashtags don't
mean anything but the thumbnail really
matters a lot and the title really
matters a lot what you put in the first
15 seconds really matters a lot there
are hacks for each platform and you get
it by tasting it and you also get it by
learning you can learn all of this stuff
you can model success you can watch tons
of videos of experts talking about these
things
so understanding that last 20 really
matters but you have to under this is
where people fall down this is where
people make so much mistakes and getting
attention you're only focused on the
hacks
and then you lose because your content
is not good enough eighty percent of
your success will be in the content
still and then twenty percent the hacks
if your content is not very good the
right instagram hashtag is not gonna
save you
if your youtube video isn't very good
the right thumbnail isn't gonna save you
always default first so my content sucks
i need to get it better now sucks in
relative terms it sucks compared to
where you want it to be that's how it
sucks but it still might be really good
for the people who are serving
you just wanted to get better you want
to keep getting better every single time
so step six is understanding the hacks
of each platform diving deep into each
one learning from experts and playing
around with it to be best in class on
that platform so if i look at youtube as
an example for me it took me 10 years to
get the 1.7 million subscribers on
instagram
i went from 6 000 100 000 in a year
really only spending half of that year
go pushing it hardcore because i
understand how to make the content i
understand how to get attention with
great content what i had to understand
was the hacks of each platform right i
had to understand what a one-minute
instagram video would look like i'd have
to understand what a picture looks like
versus the videos i'm used to i have to
understand how to do a 15 second story
on instagram and use the right hashtags
to bring people in those are the hacks
but i understand how to get attention
and so it's so much easier to grow to
the next platform and the next platform
and the next platform because 80 of it
is exactly the same and then step number
seven is love the algorithm updates
whenever there's an algorithm update
it's crazy how many people complain so
many people are complaining like ah
youtube changed their algorithm uh
instagram's changing algorithm whenever
i see that i'm so happy i'm so pumped
this is your chance to win if youtube
updates the algorithm this is your
chance to win because all the people are
ahead of you who are complaining aren't
going to do the work to figure out the
new algorithm because they wanted to go
back to what it was before
and check out how many times any of the
major social media platforms have ever
reversed an algorithm update almost
never and so while those people are
complaining and they're upset that they
lost all this attention
it's not going back to the way it used
to be so let them sit there and complain
while you're over on this side crushing
it anytime there's an algorithm update
love it learn to enjoy it go dive deep
on all the new things that are important
to that update and then apply it so you
can quickly pass all those people who
are complaining who are ahead of you
what would you say was the biggest
challenge
once you started to really take off and
grow
obviously as a small business owner when
a trend hits and everyone wants your
your product how did you handle that and
what was the biggest challenge
scalability was very hard because it was
how do i go and finance and and and
underwrite you know these things you
know where
where will i get the capital how what's
the turnaround time and i didn't have
any financial intelligence at the time
right so
you know my journey sell and you could
hustle i could sell like a hustle but
you know my journey i i i almost failed
or and lost everything several times
throughout that journey because i just
didn't know how to use the tool of money
yeah and um and and it's so hard to try
to acquire all that knowledge within the
same time how do i acquire the knowledge
of branding marketing distribution
manufacturing warehousing shipping
financial intelligence customer support
you know return on goods you know
consumption you know what i mean
it's so hard so of course i had to start
leveraging as well and creating a bunch
of strategic relationships because i
knew i needed that i knew i needed that
because you know
listen you know when you tell somebody
to stop smoking you know
a couple of times and and and after the
10th time
they know they they already have a
problem smoking they don't want to
listen to you listen forget it i'm not
even going to address it i'm going to
start smoking when you have a business
you have to answer the call or you're
closed right right so you have to plug
the dam and i knew i had to plug the dam
so i started just creating a lot of
strategic relationship and that's
actually the power broke because it is
the fact that
you know if i would have had money
when i went to those video sets
i would have paid the director i'd have
paid the producer i'd have paid the the
rapper everybody else right
if you gave me uh
twenty thousand dollars at that time and
i heard that ll cool j will wear my
stuff for five thousand dollars and the
director wants five thousand dollars to
wear it they're getting the money of
course right and they're gonna wear it
but i got into 30 40 videos with zero
dollars right because i had no way to do
it i had nothing to lose you couldn't
take anything from me i didn't have
anything yeah right exactly so so you
couldn't even give them your shirt right
you took it back i took it back right
and i said i got you later right right
elder best said you got me now but
you know when you have when you when you
when you're working with the power broke
it does a couple of things number one
it makes sure that you learn the process
yourself you can't afford to hire
anybody else so all those people out
there who who pay forty thousand dollars
for a website when it really costs five
right right or you can leverage it by
bartering or something whatever the case
is right so you have to learn the
process and what happens during that
period of time of learning the process
is
that when and if and hopefully you get
to the point that you are successful
nobody can tell you lies
you can't have somebody say well i'm not
going to tell you about shipping because
you know you're firing me and i gotta go
work it out yourself i said get the hell
out of the way i've been doing this for
eight years myself right
you know
you you get and you learn the process
number one number two is
because you don't have a lot of capital
you focus on the only thing that you can
do you don't drown an opportunity you
don't take a bunch of money and go
huh we should try a bunch of stuff here
you go here's ten thousand ten thousand
ten thousand ten thousand here go yeah
you go
all right what are we going to do with
this hat
right now
you know so
that's the process and that process is
very very important also
you learn and it brings out the
character of who you have around you
when you apparate the power of broke
what do you mean by that well if you if
you if you're busy let's open a business
today let's go take a ten thousand let's
go take a hundred thousand dollar loan
well
what happens when the money goes away
because when i didn't have anything
people worked with me for free and i i
saw who rose to the challenge i saw who
jumped ship
right i saw who was problem solvers and
problem creators
and and that's the process of activating
the power broke because to tell you the
truth the
the people who act activate the power
broke more than anybody else
are the people who are successful
because that's how they stay successful
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to know robert kiyosaki's formula
for wealth check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there the system of banking york has
nothing to do with communism or
capitalism
it's the banks run the world
the rich run the world
they don't care about communism
capitalists